all right china
china uh where'd you grow where are you
from santa barbara santa barbara
yeah and uh tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents growing up as
a kid
no i grew up with my dad and then my
stepmom my sister's mom
what happened to mom i don't know you
never knew your mom
i knew her but i didn't i don't know
what happened to her
so how was your childhood with with your
mom with your dad
i live with my my stepmom but it was it
was okay i
didn't i couldn't complain i had
everything i wanted
so no abuse nothing nothing no nothing
and you uh what kind of kid were you in
high school huh what kind of kid were
you in high school
um i went to school but i didn't stay
i i graduated but like i never went to
school so i don't really know how i
graduated
but i graduated okay and you you
left home at what age uh
16. and where'd you go at 16.
um first i moved to oak i went to
oakland
and then from oakland i went to
anaheim anaheim i went to la and now
i'm on fig roll well i live on facebook
you're working figure out
i don't yeah i guess you can say that
yeah
were you doing this up in oakland as
well yeah so you started working the
street at
what age 16 16.
you were doing that with a pimp yeah
i guess yeah how was that experience
it's me personally it's the pimp or
whatever
it's it's it's [ __ ] to me like
i guess because you don't have the
bright guy or whatever but it's [ __ ]
to me how did you get started
with through i met a guy online
you know when i moved and i moved i left
my home to move with him and
he showed me how like he told me like oh
like you can make money having sex or
whatever so i tried it and
and that that relationship lasted how
long not even like
probably two months
then you went on your own yeah you know
he had left me in anaheim
and then from anaheim i took the
greyhound bus to los
angeles in los angeles i met
i met somebody who i met another dude at
the greyhound station
and he introduced me to fig and i've
been working fake ever since she's 2013.
okay and how much money were you making
tonight
like probably five six hundred on a good
day
you ever been arrested yeah for
prostitution
loitering probably for loitering
probably like two
two three times and prostitution
it's the same thing the same thing yeah
oh i see okay
do you have kids of your own no no kids
have you had any bad experiences with uh
some of the guys you picked yeah
i've been raped i've been kidnapped i've
been held for ransom
um yeah i've been somebody tried to kill
me
it doesn't discourage you from doing
this sometimes but
if that's that's why i always have
somebody who to come with me
to know like when i what kind of car i
get in not necessarily no pimp
or it can be like a friend like a home
girl or something
but i don't i don't ever go by myself do
the girls kind of look out for each
other on the street
some of them some of them not all of
them yeah
it gets competitive too yeah
are drugs a part of your life yeah what
what drugs do you use i smuggle myth
was that meth or something
does your family know you do this um
what
your stepmom or my brother your brother
yeah i think my dad yeah
does he get you down sometimes sometimes
yeah doing this you get depressed
yeah because it's not like something
that i want to do but the money comes so
it's easy did you have dreams of doing
something else with your life when you
were younger yeah i wanted to do i
wanted to be a famous like
cosmetologist or something some makeup
yeah hair and hair you're still young
how old are you
25 25 so you can easily still do that
are you saving money doing this yeah you
are
that's great what do you think the most
misunderstood thing is
about doing this for a living what do
you think other people that don't do it
maybe that you're having sex for money
that instead of doing it for free why
not get paid for it
it's like a job
is that how you view it well yeah
instead of having sex for free but
they're
having sex with for free why not if
somebody's willing to pay why not get
paid for it
how do you think working the streets all
these years has changed you
um damn
um i know i'm not just like
how do you say it i'm not i'm not like
shy i guess like i can talk to i can
have a conversation with people
strangers yeah because when i was when i
was younger i wouldn't even talk to you
like i wouldn't even came in here
i don't look at you like you're stupid
and just like what the [ __ ]
have you been in love before have i been
in love before yeah
damn yeah
and what happened does this career get
in the way of that
no no actually i'm still with the person
i fell in love with
it's been a year okay
does this relate does this lifestyle get
in the way of romantic relationships
sometimes i think so if the person that
you're with doesn't like
they accept it but they don't accept it
they say they accept it but then they
really feel some type of way about you
doing it
right what advice would you give to a
young girl who's considering doing this
[Music]
a damn i i wouldn't i wouldn't advise it
go to school
get a job a regular job i wouldn't
advise it to nobody
all right china well thank you so much
for sharing your story you're welcome
and good luck with whatever you do from
here
okay you're still young
you